hey what is up guys mkbhd here and i
have seen
the red hydrogen smartphone slash camera
system prototype
and now in this video i'm going to share
with you so up until now visually we've
only had
one image this one render to base all of
our thoughts on the design off of and
that's great and all but jim from red
wanted to show me what they've been
working on and wanted to dispel any
myths that they're not working on
anything so that's a win for me a win
for you guys to get this video and a win
for red to actually show you something
so they had a couple prototypes to show
me one was a fit and finish prototype
with all the final materials and
dimensions and the exact look that
they're shooting for number two was a
prototype just with the working
holographic display and then one more
prototype which i'll show you guys at
the end i took a look at all of them but
i really focused in on the fit and
finish materials prototype because
that's exactly what they intend the
final project the thing that you buy to
look like
and it looked like this so yeah right
off the bat pretty intense a lot of
materials going on you have a really
industrial looking tri-panel design
looks kind of like a moto z had a baby
with a tractor like it's this part
rugged part modern look and i really
kind of like it the middle part is metal
and this logo cut out with what feels
like a jewel with the red logo in it is
pretty crazy and the top and bottom
parts are kevlar panels which is good
for antenna pass-through and of course
durability when you're using it as an
actual phone and then on the sides you
have these grips these notches like you
saw on the render it doesn't feel too
weird to hold but of course i obviously
have pretty big hands so this natural
fit for me might not be the case for
everybody i used the phones i had with
me for a little bit of a size comparison
and as you can see it's a big phone this
hydrogen is going to have a lot of room
for some serious internals with a
footprint this big you know i still fit
it in my pocket there didn't seem to be
any real problems but obviously this
will turn into a two-handed phone for a
lot of people and then the camera bump
on the back definitely more of a
placeholder than an indicator of what
the module will actually look like on
the inside but it's still pretty big
definitely couldn't tell that from the
render photo and then the button
placement is solid power button on the
right hand side which will also be flat
and double as a fingerprint reader kind
of like sony phones and then the volume
buttons are separated on the left hand
side which they probably have to be
because of all the notches and ridges
for the grips and then it also has a
dedicated video record button and you
can probably of course take photos with
it as well usb type c at the bottom and
we also see a headphone jack down there
but they're actually planning to move
that up to the top and then at the front
there's front-facing speakers a pair of
them likely a stereo pair flanking what
will be a 5.5 inch super high resolution
display and yeah those pins at the
bottom of the back as you've probably
already noticed very reminiscent of the
moto z because they will end up being
used for the same essential purpose
snap-on mods that add to the
functionality of the phone then like i
said this fit and finish prototype has
all these final materials and everything
but it doesn't have a working display
for that they had a second prototype
just with the holographic display
and let me tell you i wasn't allowed to
show this and it wouldn't have really
translated that well on video anyway but
what i can show you is my reaction to
seeing it for the first time so they
showed me some content that was shot
like normal in 2d and then converted to
four view for this crazy deep sort of 3d
look and there's also content that was
shot for this view and i gotta say if my
reaction isn't strong enough trust me i
was just kind of at a loss for words
just soaking it all in but i was pretty
impressed it definitely wasn't perfect
and it had some quirks like light
bleeding around the outside of the
display and some stuttering when i
messed with some for view gaming stuff
but this was a prototype and this would
just keep getting better with time and
hopefully be buttery smooth and
seamlessly integrated by the time it
launches next year and also if you end
up not liking it you could just never
turn it on because it has a regular 2d
mode that looks fantastic as well just
like any other normal smartphone so just
as a pure smartphone this hydrogen is
looking really interesting obviously it
has these rugged looks and these unique
features probably doesn't have things
like wireless charging probably doesn't
have waterproofing but again it's a
unique feature set and a unique price
for obviously a unique user and then as
a pocket cinema camera hydrogen is
actually even more interesting so jim
made it clear that he feels that this
can and will be the future of small form
factor cinema and i mean you can see
that being true with as good as red
stuff already is and this hydrogen
system being helium based it should also
have incredible video quality and should
outperform other mirrorless cameras and
small dslrs in an even smaller package
in fact that's what jim said is the
quality should only really be surpassed
by red's bigger cameras and the pins and
magnets module system is pretty intense
i can't really describe it too much
because obviously number one they're
prototypes and number two a lot of it is
still under development and confidential
but think of it as like moto mods on
steroids same idea with adding
functionality to the device but uh
remember that last prototype i told you
about in the beginning of the video
well that's what that was so this is
what that could look like and as you can
see attaching a module specifically for
adding a sensor and a lens mount can
already make this look pretty serious so
that for now is all i can show but
apparently in the next 30 to 45 days
they said they'll have an actual
prototype with both the fit and finish
and the holographic display in the same
body but what you just got from this
video is a quick world exclusive that's
something that red's working on that
they wanted to share with you guys so
there you have it what do you think is
that is that enough to justify
pre-ordering a thousand plus dollar
smartphone or mini pocket camera or
whatever else these things might do
let me know hopefully there'll be more
information to come but until then
that's been it thank you for watching
talk to you guys in the next one
peace
[Music]
you